now what a game over the death star
where opponents dreams come to die like
that line from mark davis the owner john
treach want to finish now players
they'll be celebrating all night this
one
yeah chris there have been a lot of wild
nights in the history of this city but
none quite like this none that had both
reward and redemption none that had 60
thousand people in a state of
exhilaration and exhaustion you know in
baltimore they like to quote the raven
forever more but when it comes to
history and hysteria
we want to hear from john gruden
died and woke up
and died again and i was like a cat i
had multiple lives tonight i don't like
playing like that it was
um tough but
again we did a lot of really good things
to win that football game tonight
and i just think
this stadium i think the people that
were here tonight will
probably go home feeling like they had a
pretty good time i just i just thought
it was really a great scene a lot of
black a lot of noise a lot of devoted
committed fans that that i just love and
cherish
and guys we can confirm
this stadium this nfl city gets legit
loud the stadium was rocking derrick
carr said it was one of the loudest
games he's ever been a part of and that
guy has been the nfl quarterback for the
raiders for eight seasons and yes
there's just a fog of ambience still
layered around this great stadium
reporting live john treach 8 sports now